I hate intro shokugeki no souma season 3
before we get into episode what do we
have to jump back a tad bit to the
second episode of the ova the top eight
from the autumn elections are sent to
meet with the elite 10 we get an
official introduction of all of the
elite 10 members seat 10 Adina seat 9 is
an ETSU yeah soon a cougar Ted a naughty
sweet seven as we all know is ishke
sixes can okay min ma Sikh 5 is psyched
oh so may sweep for is Momo a cocky neck
Bobo we're just gonna stick with mom on
that one XIII McGee Shima tops game
sweet 2 is quite possibly the sexiest
ginger you'll ever see Kobayashi you've
a no and finally c1 the sexiest albino
you'll ever see Tsukasa a she who's
always depressed or worried right out of
the gate the first thing that someone
wants to know is if any of them are
willing to have a shokugeki with their
seat on the line not a coke acoustic
later simple you know it's pretty all
decline because of the massive benefits
from being on the elite 10 but there is
a silver lining
towards the end while everybody is
getting ready to leave the 8c cuca teton
ortiz states that if soma can ever best
him in anything cooking related he'll
agree to do a shokugeki with it and now
with that out of the way we can finally
get into episode 1 we kick things off of
the introduction of the Moon Festival
where students will set up booths and
compete for sales suma figures that if
he can beat Kouga sales in the festival
he'll be forced to accept a shokugeki
challenge he learns from Hojo that Kouga
specializes in Chinese cuisine and she
takes him to his research society well
they're Kouga has his chef's whip up his
specialty Mapo tofu which is really
spicy but still delicious suma has to
figure out how to serve people in bulk
while also competing with not only cucas
dish but with his reputation that will
inevitably draw people to his booth he
figures that the only way to get an
equal amount of exposure with his booth
is to set up next to kouga's booth and
sell Chinese food also ultimately
poaching kouga's customers and in the
last scene we find out that students
that don't make a profit will be
expelled like every other competition
they've had yep so - in addition to the
booth placement soma also has his
reporter friends Oats to get him an ad
right next to kouga's ad as well
suma need someone to taste
dishes so he goes to Eddie mill which
she has talked into by audit Oh since
her and Soma have been getting along he
learns more about Chinese cuisine from
them and also gets help from Megami who
is the only other person working at his
booth since everybody else is busy
everyone starts to set up for the event
with Google having a behemoth booth next
to sohma's modest little cart after
experimenting with some different
recipes some I decided to sell black
pepper buns at his booth episode 3 at
the end of the verse they Kouga managed
to get first place in sales for the
central area while soma finishes in 40th
on the second day sales cuca gets first
place again while so my managed to climb
up to 35th after adding a new noodle
dish to his menu yep so for suma had
noticed that the long wait was
irritating customers trying to eat at
cucas booth ah day 4 soma adds tables
and chairs to his booth and switches to
his own version of the Mapo tofu dish
this intrigues a lot of the customers to
try it and after they see how good it is
the booth starts to get a lot of
traction things start to get pretty
hectic though with so many customers
showing up and only him and Megami to
serve them that's the cue for Subaru to
show up who agreed to help after being
asked to buy soma he uses his perfect
profiling to learn the recipes that soma
had made and helps prepare the Mapo tofu
documents on me and ecoo me all show up
to relieve the workload as well allowing
them to get first place in the sales on
the fourth day yep so by on the fifth
and final day of the festival Kouga
beats soma and wins and overall sales
which you think would be a good thing
for cuca but he actually had an
agreement with the first seat Tsukasa to
have a shokugeki if he got first place
all five days because he lost a soma on
the fourth day and soma lost in overall
sales there's nobody getting their
shokugeki today the second seat window
takes soma and mega me to eat at
tsukasa's booth where soma realizes just
how much stronger he is and here's where
the show takes a rather ominous turn
when Edina runs into her father Asami
McAtee again in a not-so-pleasant
reunion suma comes by hoping to try some
of EDD eNOS food at her booth but
instead ends up walking in on this
uncomfortable situation Amina's
grandfather shows up to his core
off of school grounds because he is
technically banned from the Academy
really get a bit of a plot twist though
when Asami reveals that six of the elite
10 members eizan keno Kimmy site Tomo
malindo and Tsukasa all voted in favor
of Asami becoming the new director of
the Academy forcing sin saman to step
down episode 6 - Ichigo and again happen
to run into one another while they're
both out on business well together Dean
gets a call informing him of that Asami
had taken over as the new director it's
also revealed that Asami was actually
the third seat behind game and Joey judo
when they attended the Academy we then
get a flashback of his AMI and why he
was banished
he had isolated Edina as a child and
started brainwashing her to do only as
he says I know what you're thinking no
this is not a hentai plot but it could
be and even if it was I would never
watch it without a proper VPN unless you
want a three-letter organization showing
up at your door I'd advise that you do
the same thing when sends a man had
found out about the brainwashing he put
an end to it and exiled his son but now
that he's back he's implementing these
methods again starting with the
isolation of Edina from her secretary
Hisako which is just unrealistic anybody
who's seen a good hand ty knows that you
target the friend also soon Zaman has a
secret meeting with so much to ask him
to save a dina from her father call me
crazy but i probably would have went to
cps first but yeah let's go with the
teenager i guess that works
meanwhile Hisako had failed in Alice on
what's going on so they work together to
break a Dina free and run away with her
they have no place for a Dina to stay
but luckily they ended up outside of
polar star dormitory and Megami invites
them inside after all the members of
polar star are informed on the situation
they are more than happy to let a Dina
stay there oh darn a hot girl with the
big rock shows up and needs a place to
stay I guess we can make some room
episode 7 as his first order of business
the director orders all of research
societies and any other groups of
students to be shut down
he also introduces the new group that
will be leaving what will be taught to
the students called central soon after
eizan comes to pull their star to
announce its closure and in response to
this so much challenges him to a
shokugeki to keep polar star open hazen
is more than happy to accept any
challenges from clubs or groups being
shut down but that's just because he
paid
all of the judges for the shokugeki x'
to make him the winner after seeing this
all of the clubs and groups were send
their challenges as they see that they
can't win zuma decides to go through
with his challenge anyways because
there's no other way to protect
PolarStar or didn't OD let's do this
less than kiddo
show could he keep as the shokugeki gets
underway Asian sent some of his goons to
vacate the dorm ahead of schedule yep so
date good eviction commences with ace
and squad launching their attack on
polar star but the polar star members
rally together to hold them off until
the shokugeki concludes Zoomer just
focuses on the match though and taunts
eizan which makes him want to cook
seriously two shots Omaha hazen serves
up a Hainanese chicken rice dish which
thoroughly impress is the judges to him
a response to this with a special
chicken wing tip gyoza dish which is so
good that it forces Asian to acknowledge
his skills
the judges are so enticed by the aroma
from the dish that they figure what's
the harm of trying it even though
they're paid off to make eizan win they
realized that the dish is spectacular
even though it wasn't cooked in the
conventional methods that central is
imposing on everybody
this makes them reconsider if there is
only one correct way to cook so they
have to give their votes to soma winning
him the shokugeki let's be honest to
real life they would have been like damn
that's good but I gotta get paid and
then they would have learned some under
the bus he would have lost his job gave
up cooking started half under a bridge I
would have been a whole thing episode 9
fuller star members celebrate their
victory and ishke explains that thanks
to some was matched the judging was
changed to be fair and is no longer
rigged miscues all the research
societies to reissue their challenges to
fight for their club survival a couple
of days later ish kakuka and mega Shima
are removed from the elite ten because
they didn't vote in favor of Asami
taking over as director the elite 10 and
other central members then launched
their campaign called hunt the survivors
to wipe out all of the club's
challenging them Alison Rio show up
because Rio had gotten mad at one of the
central members kusunoki Atlanta doe and
agreed to a shokugeki with him episode
10 min tato busts out his trump card a
combi steamer and cryo mill to make a
salmon confit flambe with a side of
salmon ice cream which sounds nasty
to compete with this Rios serves up a
Kubiak which brings the decision to a
stalemate
while the judges further analyze the
dishes to figure out which one was
better
we get a flashback of Rio on his Stasi
Anna who was assigned to a curry
restaurant where he was ridiculed by the
owner for not knowing enough about
spices this made him try to learn more
about seasoning his foods and ultimately
gave his dish an edge leading to his
victory in the shokugeki episode 11
alice comes face to face with the sami
for the first time who she hates because
while he was isolating eddie not as a
child he tore up letters that Alice had
wrote to her she tells him off in front
of everybody and says that a demon needs
to learn to stand up for herself the
next day summer gets a bit of a surprise
when he finds out that his class is
being led by Tsukasa and he ends up
volunteering to be his assistant because
everybody else was too scared Tsukasa is
impressed by his skills and asks him to
join Central as his assistant every
night he Sacco and Megami overhear this
from the hallway while eavesdropping
suyama turns him down at first but
things end up escalating until Tsukasa
challenges soma to a shokugeki with the
first seat on the line but if someone
loses he'll have to join Central as we
all know someone never shied away from a
challenge so he accepts and while they
are cooking Central's true plan is
revealed their overall goal is to shut
down all of the restaurants in Japan and
replace them with their own after
hearing this soma decides that he can't
lose in order to protect his family's
diner episode well booth soma and
Tsukasa finished their Venetian dishes
and soma brings in Eddie Naruto and
Megami to act as the judges they're
hesitant at first but it great to do
their best not to be biased after
comparing the dishes they declare that
tsukasa's dish is better
however after Tsukasa had tasted so most
unorthodox cooking he decides say he's
too unpredictable and he doesn't want
him to be his assistant since this isn't
exactly an official shokugeki Tsukasa
decides to call it a draw and Selma
doesn't have to join Central later on
mega Miku me and Madhu we have to
compete in shokugeki x' to protect their
clubs from central which they all end up
winning Azam even visits PolarStar
dormitory where everybody finds out that
he used to be a part of polar star
during its Golden Age with Joey judo and
gain well talking as AMI speaks very
highly of Joey judo and is cooking in
response to this soma reveals that Joey
judo is his father
right as Idina is coming out and hears
him yes you should remember that Joey
Trudeau is adding his role model and
she's been wanting to cook for him ever
since she met him as a child
but should I know about the connection
between him and soma naturally this is a
big shock to both Idina and Asami and
then Asami goes on to explain that his
main goal is to bring down the system
that ruined Joey cheeto I'm gonna be
doing the future seasons and that'll be
in the bottom Otto never I'm finished
with it or you can check out all the
shokugeki recaps in this playlist here
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing I
hate more than intros is our troops